des files d'attentes à ne plus en voir
le bout elle les cubains se pressent au
portillon pour profiter de cette
nouvelle règle si le dollar était
interdit sur l'île jusqu'en 1993 il est
depuis 2004 possible de changer des
devises américaines en pesos locaux ce
qui impliquait toutefois une lourde taxe
de 10%
mais pour soutenir une économie à la
peine en pleine pandémie
l'exécutif a décidé de supprimer cette
taxation
nous allons supprimer cette taxe de 10%
dans un contexte d'hostilité et de
renforcement de l'embargo des états unis
il est désormais également possible de
payer directement en dollars dans
certains supermarchés et quelques autres
commerces
une décision qui semble plutôt bien
accueillie par la population
je pense que le gouvernement essayait de
récupérer les deux vices qui sont dans
la rue de manière à pouvoir acheter à
l'étranger
c'est positif du point de vue de la
possibilité qu'ont les gens d'acheter
des choses si vous avez les dollars
allez les changer je pense que c'est
positif oui mais selon moi il faut que
cette mesure soit davantage élargi pour
éviter qu'il y ait un agglutinent mans
de personnes ici effectivement nombreux
sont les cubains avoir pris d'assaut les
magasins concernés qui représente
seulement quelques dizaines de commerces
sur l'île des mesures qui permettront
selon le président cubain meigel dias
cannelle non seulement de résister mais
aussi d'aller de l'avant et développer
l'économie